[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL AZUMA: This
morning, we're
going to start off this day
of content by talking about--
I should get my clicker here--
by talking about best practices.
Best practices-- we all
love best practices.
It's the wisdom accumulated
from long and varied experience.
Best practices help us
get things done safely,
efficiently, and effectively.
Much of what we talk about
in a conference like this
is best practices.
I mean, take web
apps, for example.
Many, perhaps even
most, of our web
apps today look
something like this.
You have kind of a standard
three-tier design, a front end,
JavaScript, mobile app, what
have you, talks to HTTP,
probably REST to a back end.
You have workers that
are probably stateless,
and they talk to
a database that's
a separate tier database.
Now, there is a lot of benefits
to writing your apps this way,
to design your apps
in a standardized way.
Some of them are
obvious, but one of them
is, when it comes to deployment,
your app will fit well.
Your app fits well with
the tools in the ecosystem.
You fit well with Kubernetes.
You fit well with serverless.
Your app fits into
the cloud ecosystem.
So you have all these
resources available to help you
deploy, scale, secure,
and manage your app,
if it's a conventional
three-tier, stateless app,
if it follows those
best practices.
So best practices--
very important.
In this session, we're going
to throw those best practices
away.
We're going to talk
about those times
when we just have to
chuck the best practices.
We need to push the
boundaries and break out
of our conventions
because we need
to create the next new thing.
So, of course, when
you do that, when
you break convention,
you start to lose that fit.
You start to lose that fit.
Tasks like deployment,
integration with other systems,
become more challenging.
I'm going to tell
you about an app
that I worked on,
where it didn't
follow a lot of those
conventions that we're used to.
I'll talk about
the journey that I
took to make it work,
make it fit in the cloud.
We'll talk about
some other platforms
that don't follow
conventional cloud practices,
and how they're
adapting to the cloud.
And we'll talk about how
your unconventional apps,
some things that you can do
to make them fit in the cloud.
Now, of course, this is
not going to be, like,
an exhaustive survey of all
the different things that you
can do.
I mean, there is just no way.
We're going to focus on
just a couple of examples,
a couple of ways that apps
sometimes break the mold,
and that the techniques that
we're going to discuss here
are also not the--
they're not the
end all and be all.
They're not the final say here.
They may work well
for some apps.
They may be a terrible
idea for others.
So rather, the goal here is to
take a look at some examples.
Take a look at some
examples and just get
some ideas flowing, so that your
creativity can get unlocked.
So as you are faced with
deploying your unique app,
with its unique challenges,
you have a starting point.
You have kind of a starting
point in some ideas
that can stimulate
your own thinking.
So a quick introduction
before I get too far.
My name is Daniel.
I work at Google as an
engineer on the Ruby team.
Any Ruby developers here?
Ruby?
OK, a few of you.
I work for you.
My job is to make the
cloud better for Rubyists.
My team works on API
clients, runtimes
for App Engine, developer tools,
tutorials, the documentation,
basically everything
that you need in order
to make the cloud work
for Rubyists, for you
as Ruby developers.
And we're part of
a group of teams
that focus on different
programming language
communities.
So I work on Ruby.
I also do some work on the
Elixir programming language.
Any Elixir developers
here, by the way?
One?
Oh, awesome.
How about Erlang?
Erlang's another
related language.
Any Erlangers?
Oh, great, great.
You guys do anything on Google
Cloud with Elixir and Erlang?
AUDIENCE: Starting to.
DANIEL AZUMA: Starting to?
Great.
Yeah, so we're doing a
little bits with Erlang now,
and a little bit with Elixir.
It's a lot of fun.
You know, I've been learning
Elixir myself for the past four
years or so.
But for the rest of us,
we have an opportunity now
to learn something
new, so that's great.
Elixir and Erlang are both
closely related languages.
They're both functional
programming languages.
They both target a
platform called OTP.
Actually, OTP is
part of the platform.
There's a bunch of
related components.
There's a VM.
There is a runtime system.
OTP relates to the library,
the standard library,
and frameworks associated
with the platform.
But it's a really interesting
platform for web development.
It has powerful features
around concurrency
and around distributed systems.
And it also has some
really interesting features
around fault tolerance
and error recovery.
But on the flip
side, Erlang and OTP,
the architecture of an app
written for this platform
can be different from
the way that we're
used to writing web
apps in other languages,
like Node.js, or Ruby,
or Go, or anything else.
And this difference is something
that I first encountered when
I was first learning Elixir.
I had joined a study
group with some friends
from a local meetup.
This was about four years ago.
And we did a book study
in the study group,
and then four of
us got together,
and we said, you know,
let's put some of the things
that we've learned into practice
and do a project together.
So we did this project.
This is a screenshot of what
we built. As you can see,
it's a simple
multiplayer tank game.
We wrote it as a web
app, and you've probably
seen this sort of thing before.
You drive a tank around a maze.
You have other players
that are online with you,
and they're driving
around tanks,
and you try to shoot them down.
So it's online.
It's multiplayer.
It's real-time.
Now, none of us were
professional game developers.
This is the first time that
we've done something like this.
And we're trying to learn
that at the same time
we're learning Elixir,
so it was a lot of fun.
It was a challenge.
But we had to figure
out a bunch of things
while we were doing this.
And in particular, we learned
that doing this kind of thing
as a web app presents
some challenges.
We figured out early
on that the game logic,
you know, keeping
the game state,
tracking the objects
on the screen,
doing collision
detection, all that stuff,
it has to be run over
here on the server side
because we have multiple
players, multiple clients
connected, so we need some
central source of truth
for what's going on.
So that means we have to stream
updates across to the clients.
So this is an action game.
This is a real-time game.
We want 20, 30 frames per
second, so REST requests,
HTTP, not going to
work, too much latency.
So we changed that
to a WebSocket.
And in general, we started
to tinker with this web app
architecture.
We started to
change things around
because of what
our use case was,
what our requirements were.
We looked at the
game logic itself,
and we realized, OK, this is
a long-running game simulation
that we're running here.
This is a background process
that's continually updating
the game stage, frame by frame.
And so it has to operate
pretty rapidly, again,
20 or 30 frames per second.
So if the game state is
kept in a separate database,
again, probably
too much latency.
So we chucked the
database and, instead, we
kept the game state in memory
in our back-end servers.
So?
Now, imagine we've got this
game simulation running on one
of those servers, say this one.
Now, there's no guarantee
that it's the same server
that all the players WebSockets
are connected to, right?
The load balancer is just
going to connect the client
to whatever it connects it to.
So we were thinking, OK,
how do we deal with this?
And there are a few ways.
You can bypass
the load balancer.
You can customize
Or you can let the servers
talk to each other,
make our back-end servers parts
of an interconnected cluster,
and so that they can forward
messages, back and forth,
to wherever they need to be.
So again, we were tinkering
with the app architecture,
tinkering with it.
And we ended up
landing on something
that looks kind of like this.
And we say, yeah,
OK, this'll work.
This would work.
This will work
for our tank game.
And turns out that Elixir
and OTP support this kind
of architecture quite well.
They have stateful processes,
state kept in memory.
There are nodes that
are interconnected,
that can forward messages
back and forth to each other.
This kind of real-time
distributed system
is the kind of thing
that Elixir, that OTP,
are particularly designed for.
And so as we were learning OTP,
as we were learning Elixir,
this is how we ended
up designing our app,
so a little bit unconventional
compared with most web apps.
So all this was going well.
You know, we had our game.
It was working.
It was playable.
We were having fun,
the four of us,
and we decided, OK, let's
demo it to our meetup group.
So let's [INAUDIBLE] and
let's get the whole meetup
group together, and they
could all connect up,
and we can play
the game together.
And we can show them how it
works, how we developed it.
So that was a great plan.
Now we had to decide
how we were going
to deploy the game so that
people could connect up to it.
Well, this was 2015,
four years ago.
And this is a time
that saw the emergence
of a really interesting
deployment technology.
Kubernetes was
interesting and important
at the time it came
out because of the way
that it oriented the
industry around container
practices, the way that
it's codified the practices
of container-based deployment.
Technically, Kubernetes
is a very flexible system.
And we'll talk a little bit
about that a little later.
But in practice, its usage is
actually pretty opinionated.
Conventionally, Kubernetes
wants your servers
to be stateless,
no, not stateful.
It wants them to be
transient, and not persistent.
It wants them to be independent,
and not interconnected.
This didn't match the way
that our app was designed.
Yeah, you have Kubernetes
StatefulSets also.
They were called
PetSets at the time.
But even those didn't quite fit
with what we were trying to do.
We were keeping
states in memory as
these long-running processes.
So when we tried to deploy our
tank game using Kubernetes,
we ran afoul of some
of these opinions.
And at the time, we said,
ugh, let's just punt on this.
We just wanted to get something
working for our meetup,
so we punted on it.
But it does bring up a very
interesting and important
question, and it's
something that we eventually
came back to when we
started thinking about,
how would we really deploy
this if it were a production
application?
We started asking
ourselves, is Kubernetes,
even though it's
embodying what's
now kind of becoming
cloud best practices,
is Kubernetes just not the
right technology for deploying
an app like this?
Are containers just not
the right technology?
Is the cloud itself, cloud best
practices, just not designed
for apps like this?
And we were not alone in
asking some of these questions.
The Elixir and OTP
community, as a whole,
has been debating this quite
a bit over the past few years.
There's a feeling
that containers
and conventional cloud practices
just don't fit with the way
that our apps look.
Because of this,
the OTP community
has been kind of slow
in adopting the cloud.
So later, when we came
back to this question,
and we started
thinking, OK, if we
wanted to deploy this
to say, Kubernetes
Engine, what would we do?
What should we do when our
app breaks the rules, when
our platform breaks the rules?
Can it be done?
Can I deploy this
to GKE and actually
have it work reasonably well?
So let's take a closer
look at this app,
and where does it not fit.
Where does it not
fit with the cloud,
and what can we do about it?
Well, first, the workers in
our app are interconnected.
They form a cluster, and they
have to talk to each other.
So now, of course, normal
Kubernetes practice
is for replicas to be
independent, right?
But let's set normal practice
aside for the moment.
If your workers need
to intercommunicate,
what does that mean?
Practically, that
means they need
to know where each other are.
You know, they need to know
how to reach each other.
They need to have each other's
IP addresses, any credentials
that they need to
talk to each other.
There are ways to get
that sort of information.
Most of us treat Kubernetes
as a deployment tool,
but it really is, first
and foremost, an API.
It's an API that you can
use to build deployment
tools, to build ops tools.
It provides all sorts
of useful information
about the shape of
your deployment.
And you can talk to this
API from within your app.
So that might look
something like this.
This is Elixir codes.
It's adapted from our
tank game, so don't
worry about the details here.
I just want to point
out a couple of things.
Kubernetes provides you with
your pod service account
credentials, the credentials
you need to talk to other things
in the Kubernetes cluster
and the Kubernetes ecosystem.
These are available
in the file system.
So we're setting the
path to those credentials
here as a constant.
Kubernetes DNS also
provides the domain name.
It exposes the domain
name for itself,
for its own API endpoint, so
we're setting that constant.
And we can use that information.
We have everything we need to
send requests to the Kubernetes
API from within your app.
So this code, for
example, it returns
a list of the IP
addresses for all the pods
in your deployments.
So once you have
those addresses,
pods can reach each other.
So what if, as each pod in
your Kubernetes deployment
spins up, as each
container spins up,
we ran that code
during initialization?
We contact the Kubernetes API.
We get a list of all the other
pods running, a list of IP
addresses.
And then we can use that to
establish any connections
that we need to add that
new worker to the cluster.
We run all that
during initialization.
Now, when a worker
is shutting down,
we want to remove
it from the cluster.
So we might need to do some
disconnection, some clean-up.
And again, you can use tools
that Kubernetes gives you,
such as lifecycle hooks.
Well, many of you are
already familiar with this.
You can configure your
pods in your containers,
with your pods
with a PreStop hook
that gets executed when
that pod is terminated.
You can also trap
the term signal
that sends to your container
when it gets terminated.
So you have these initialization
and these shutdown
hooks available, and
they can enable your app
to maintain an
interconnected cluster,
like our tank game needed.
This is a pretty common use
case for Elixir developers,
so the community has
developed a library for it.
But even if you're not
an Elixir developer,
and I know most of us are not,
if your app needs information
about its own
deployment environments,
just a little digging
into the Kubernetes API
will yield a lot of
useful information.
All right, so far,
pretty straightforward.
What else is our app
doing differently?
Well, our workers are hosting
these long-running processes,
these long-running game
simulations that keep state.
And not only keep state, they're
not just stateful processes,
but they're keeping
state in memory.
So why is this an issue?
Well, most normal
deployment practices
assume that you can bring
down a container at any time.
You can bring down
a worker at anytime.
They assume that back
ends are transient.
They assume back
ends are stateless.
And we're breaking those
rules because we're
running these game
simulations in memory.
And so when Kubernetes wants
to take down that container,
say it wants to scale down, it
wants to do a rolling updates,
we have a problem.
Unless-- unless, what
if there was a way
to move that running game
to a different worker?
This is a technique known
as process migration,
moving processes or state
from one node to another
in the distributed
system in general,
maybe within a cluster of
workers within Kubernetes.
There are a number of different
forms of process migration.
There's been a lot of research
done into it over the years.
But in our case, it's fairly
simple, fairly straightforward.
First thing you
need to do is you
need to be able to
checkpoint a process.
You need to be able to pause it.
You need to capture its
state and serialize it.
Now for a game simulation,
conceptually, this
is not that difficult.
Your process is just
this long-running process that's
updating the game world, frame
by frame, so you just need to
capture one of those frames,
you know, capture that
as a big data structure.
And OTP actually provides
you with a number
of tools that help with
that, capturing, managing,
serializing state.
So next thing is you
need to be able to move
that state elsewhere and
continue running the process.
One straightforward
way to do that
is to use a
message-queuing service.
So when a node is
about to go down--
remember, we have those
Kubernetes shutdown hooks,
right?
So we use that.
You pause the game--
pause any games-- there
might be multiple games
running on that node.
We serialize their
state, and then we
push them up to the queue.
Then some other
node in the cluster
can pull those [INAUDIBLE]
games down from the queue
and resume running them.
So now we've effectively
moved that game from one node
to another node.
And there are, of
course, a number
of queuing systems available
for you to use those.
There's RabbitMQ.
There's Apache Kafka.
If you're using Google
Cloud, you might just
use Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
And here's what that
would look like.
You can create one topic
for process migration.
You use a single
shared subscription
for all the running
nodes to listen to.
And when a container
is about to go down,
you serialize games,
publish those game states
up to that Pub/Sub topic.
Each of those games will
then get pulled down
by one of the other
nodes that's listening in
on that subscription.
Since we have a single
shared subscription,
it will distribute games
among all the listeners.
So if you want to implement
a system like this,
Pub/Sub might be a
reasonable way to do it.
There are a few things to
watch for, some things that we
encountered.
If you're familiar with
process migration in general,
you probably know that
one of the big challenges
is maintaining communication--
maintaining communication.
If you have a communication
channel with a process,
say, you're a player
connected to a running game
and that game moves to a
different node, what do you do?
How do you reconnect
to that game?
How do you find the new
locations for that process?
One way to handle this
is to create and maintain
a kind of address book,
mapping from a process ID,
or a name, or some kind of
identifier for that process,
for that game, say, to the
location where it can be found.
In Elixir or OTP, this
is handled by a construct
known as a registry.
So that's something that
we use for our tank game.
You could use a low-length
latency database like Redis.
You could use some
distributed state mechanism,
like a CRDT, anything that
you can use as a shared,
consistent source of truth.
So keep an address book so
that you can forward messages,
so that you can
reconnect anything
that needs to talk to those
processes that are moving.
Another issue to consider
is load balancing.
If you use Google Cloud
Pub/Sub, for example,
it'll approximately load
balance across the listeners
that are listening in on
this shared subscription.
But there aren't
guarantees here.
So if you want more
control, or maybe you
need to distribute load
based on the actual CPU
load on those workers,
so it'd probably
be a good idea to do something
like monitoring load.
You can use a product like
sector upgrade monitoring.
There are third-party solutions
for that sort of thing.
Based on that information,
then you can selectively
enable or disable
listeners, or you can
send [INAUDIBLE] as necessary.
Some other queuing systems also
have some interesting features
that can be helpful for
something like this.
If you're using
RabbitMQ, for example,
subscribers can
specify a priority.
And so you can set a priority
based on, say, the load
on your worker.
One other item, depending
on the queuing system
that you're using, it might be
possible under rare conditions
for a message to get
delivered more than once.
This is possible under
Google Cloud Pub/Sub,
sometimes possible under
other queuing systems.
So you might need a mechanism
to detect and resolve this case.
And that's another case
where a process registry
can help because it's a shared
source of truth for where
a process needs to
be running, then
you can use that to resolve who
wins, if multiple workers try
to pull down a process.
So just a few considerations
to be aware of.
All right, so we've talked
about queuing systems as a way
to do process migration.
And they're a common way
for process migration,
but they're not the only way.
Our tank game was
written in OTP in Elixir,
and that ecosystem
actually has access
to a lot of really
interesting tools
for writing distributed
applications, distributed
systems.
You could take advantage
of tools in the platform
that you're running
for, the ecosystem,
to build process
migration directly.
So this is actually
what we ended up doing.
We wrote our own process
migration in Elixir,
and it turns out that there
are some nice libraries
available in the
ecosystem as open source,
so that did most of
what we needed to do.
So again, most of us aren't
Elixir developers here,
so I won't go down that rabbit
hole describing all of that.
If you are interested
in a deeper dive in some
of the things that
you can do, you
can look for this talk, where
I did an ElixirConf last year.
It's on YouTube.
But in general, there
are multiple ways
that you can implement
something like this.
And there are some
trade-offs, of course,
between different
implementations.
There are performance versus
complexity trade-offs.
One of the reasons
we rolled our own,
and did that within
the Elixir ecosystem,
we pass messages back and
forth as OTP messages.
And one of the reasons we
did that was performance.
We actually got really, really
incredible performance out
of that.
But it did mean that we
had to do some custom code.
So there are some trade-offs.
There are reliability concerns,
security considerations,
that you might need
to think about.
So you'll need to vet those
concerns for your app,
depending on your
particular use case.
But in general,
for our tank game,
we found process migration
really interesting.
It's a really interesting
thing because it actually
let us have it both ways--
let us have it both ways.
It let us build an
unconventional app.
It had a stateful back
ends, processes in memory,
all the performance and
interactivity benefits
that came with it.
And it let us deploy that with
conventional cloud practices,
with conventional Kubernetes,
and we got all the autoscaling,
all the CI/CD benefits, all
the cloud kind of managements
and ops benefits
that come with that.
We got it both ways.
So it was a really
interesting exercise for us,
and we learned quite a bit.
Of course, it is possible
that process migration,
in particular, is not
appropriate for your app.
Some workloads might
not lend themselves
to pausing a running process,
snapshotting, and serializing,
or performance
might be an issue.
You know, for our tank game, we
got really good performance out
of it, maybe a few
tens of milliseconds
in order to migrate a game.
So it was totally fine
for our application.
People's internet connections
will lag for more than that.
But maybe your app
has more stringent
real-time requirements.
So let's take a look
at some other ways
that you can deal
with things like this,
within memory states.
Now if you're working
on a large-scale, say,
multiplayer gaming system--
professional gaming systems
often divide servers
into separate pools.
You have a set of
servers maybe that
are for normal
web-like requests,
so things like profile
pages, lobbies, and so forth.
And these can be
managed and deployed
with familiar techniques
like Kubernetes.
But maybe game simulations,
maybe you need to do games,
like, as long-running background
processes, states in memory,
and maybe those things
can't be interrupted.
So you might want to run those
on a separate pool of servers
that are orchestrated
differently.
So if you have some
servers that follow
a different set of rules,
can you deal with that?
What can you do about that?
Well, fortunately, as
we mentioned before,
Kubernetes is a highly
flexible system.
It has opinions, but
it can be customized
to implement different
sets of rules,
even within the same
overall deployment.
Agonase is a project that's
taken advantage of that.
Some of you have
heard about this.
We've talked about--
talk about it
in some of the other sessions.
It provides tools to manage
dedicated game servers,
matchmaking some of the various
needs of a gaming system.
It's being developed jointly by
Google Cloud and Ubisoft, which
is a large game developer.
So it's well worth
checking out if you're
interested in working in
high-performance gaming,
or anything else that
might be really similar.
Sorry.
OK, let's take a look
at one more example.
One of the more interesting
features of Elixir and OTP
is hot code upgrade--
hot code upgrade.
The OTP platform
actually has the ability
to hot-upgrade your
code while it's running.
You can have a code
base running code,
and then it can seamlessly
translate to a new code base
while that code is running.
Does that seem far-fetched?
Why would you ever need
to do something like that?
Well, hot code upgrade
comes from OTP's roots
as a telecom platform.
It was originally developed
by Erlang back in the '80s,
or by Ericsson back in the '80s.
They developed the Erlang
language and the OTP platform.
They developed it for
things like-- applications
like switches.
Say you have a switch that's
in the middle of running
live phone calls.
You have software
running on that switch.
You can upgrade, if
you want to upgrade
the software on that switch,
while those calls are running.
You don't want to
disconnect your customers.
You don't want to interrupt
those phone calls.
So capabilities like
hot code upgrades
were developed during this time.
And it's a really
powerful capability.
But it does seem to be kind
of contrary to what we usually
do in the cloud, right?
We kill old containers,
and we spin up new ones.
So what if you wanted to
use something like hot code
upgrade in the cloud?
What if, you know, it seemed
appropriate for your app?
And there are apps that could
take advantage of something
like this.
Well, here's how one service
is solving this problem.
Gigalixir is a
platform as a service.
It was designed especially
with Elixir and OTP
applications in mind.
It's not a Google product, but
it has some really interesting
ideas.
They realize that containers,
and kind of conventional cloud
practices, contain
orchestration,
is still valuable, still
usable for managing your cloud
resources, and for doing
things like updating libraries,
updating your OS, updating
your dependencies,
But containers don't work
so well for hot upgrade,
for updating software in-place.
So Gigalixir developed
a hybrid approach,
and it looks kind of like this.
In traditional deployment,
you might create
a build of your app in Docker.
So you have all the
dependencies, the OS,
and your app all in a
single Docker image.
And this is what you deploy
to Kubernetes, to Cloud Run,
for example.
Now, Gigalixir modifies this.
They separate your app from
the OS and dependencies.
So they still build the OS
and dependencies in Docker,
but the app is built
as a separate image.
And it gets mounted into
the container as a volume.
So since your app lives
on a separate volume,
it has the ability to modify
itself on that volume,
even though it's running
in the container.
So now we can perform
hot code upgrade
without taking down
that container.
And then, of course, if we want
to make these larger but less
frequent changes to the OS
or the dependency layer,
these can be done using
familiar Kubernetes techniques,
so again, a hybrid approach--
hybrid approach.
This is just another way that a
service has found creative ways
to meet the needs of
unconventional apps,
while continuing to fit into
kind of a cloud ecosystem.
All right, what have
we learned here?
What have we learned?
Well, we've seen just a few,
just a few techniques that
might be useful for deploying
unconventional apps,
particularly stateful apps,
real-time interactive apps.
We saw that you can use
the Kubernetes API to query
your deployments environments.
We saw how we can
use that information
to establish communication
among your server replicas,
so if your server replicas
need to forward messages
to each other.
We saw some ways that you
can use process migration
to preserve server
side state, even
to preserve running
server side processes
when you redeploy your back end.
We saw how some projects
are extending the Kubernetes
infrastructure, and others
are using hybrid techniques
to meet the needs of
highly interactive apps.
In general, we've
seen that you don't
need to throw away our tools
and our best practices.
Often, we just need
to stretch them a bit.
We just need to add
to them a little bit.
And this is important.
It's important to think
in terms of stretching
because this process of
stretching our practices,
that could be the basis of the
next generation of our Cloud
Tools and our Cloud
Deployment practices,
and maybe, maybe even the
evolution of the cloud itself.
I mean, take
serverless, for example.
There's a lot of talk about
serverless these days, right?
There's a lot of talk, a
lot of excitement, maybe
some skepticism.
Today, serverless
is often equated
with functions as a service.
Now, functions are awesome for
some workloads, some workloads.
But, I mean, let's be real.
It won't work for our
tank game, all right.
The functions are not the end
all and be all of serverless,
and we've seen that.
We've seen that during this
conference in Cloud Run.
Cloud Run expands what's
possible under the umbrella
of serverless.
It expands it beyond functions,
just functions per se,
just a bit, just a bit.
What if we were to take
that a little bit further?
What if we were to imagine
the future serverless where
we could even have stateful
processes coexisting
with stateless functions?
What could that look like?
What should it look like?
Would it support
process migration?
Would it support game servers?
Would it support
hot code upgrade?
Does it look totally different?
Maybe it would be
a terrible idea.
I don't know.
I don't think anyone knows yet.
But I think that's the fun part.
That's the fun part of where
we're at right now in cloud.
And it's the kind
of question that
can, and should, be driven
by our unconventional apps,
by apps like our
tank game, by apps
that you are developing today.
That's why I love being around
technologies like Elixir,
and like OTP, and
the communities
that are around those,
developers like you who
are pushing the envelope,
who understand that it's OK,
sometimes, to be unconventional.
Because you are
the ones catalyzing
those changes, the next
generation in cloud,
coming up with the wild ideas,
stretching our best practices,
and creating more
powerful tools,
and moving the industry forward.
Because we know that
what's conventional today
might not be adequate
for tomorrow.
So here we've talked
about just a few ideas,
just a few techniques that might
be useful, or at least maybe
interesting, maybe.
I'm sure you have
your own ideas.
That's the point here.
I encourage you to come
up with your own ideas,
to share them, get involved.
This is your cloud.
This is your cloud here.
This is your community.
I want to hear your ideas.
Your colleagues here
want to hear your ideas.
Google wants to hear your ideas.
What will things look
like beyond that horizon?
Let's move the cloud
forward together.
Thank you for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]